[Music]
good morning welcome to a new project
camp update this is number 58 in every
eight video we're gonna talk about our
current problems or challenges and we're
going to do a q a so we're going to
answer some questions from you guys at
the end of this video
but before we're going to look into our
new challenges let's have a look at one
of the previous ones which was all about
forest fire so we got more and more
worried some are come that there will be
forest fires
and they're actually at this point many
forest fires here going on there's now
one big one here about two hours away
from us with 1500 firefighters there
many planes it's been ongoing for a few
days
many hectares burned down actually in
the whole portugal this year already 50
000 hectares burned down and it's hard
to put in perspective these numbers like
i never really got it but since we have
a land here and we start talking more in
hectares i can imagine it a bit better
so for instance like 5 000 times our
land here that is burned down which is
just
a lot
um but anyway we made a special update
about the whole fire situation here have
a look at them if you're interested so
yeah for us this would just be a longer
ongoing challenge
anyway we're gonna have a look now at
our current challenges but for that we
actually just have to wait a few hours
to really see it because now it's
morning fresh chilly good
but in a few hours
yeah challenge number one it's hot i get
it
heat waving europe it's hot in many
places but it feels
portugal and it's even warmer and
especially being here on the countryside
with minimal shelter
makes you feel even more hot i mean we
have metal containers
and a black plastic roof which doesn't
help to cool down i guess in a village
or something you would have a house a
roof walls maybe air conditioning
but here you're very exposed to the heat
and you really feel it
i mean fair enough usually i wouldn't
sit in the middle of a field in the
middle of the day with the sun on my hat
this just to make point that it's warm
and i think actually the coolest place
we have now is in the bottom of the ruin
with the big granite stones
but yeah we're renovating so it's all
dusty so you can't be there
but this really affects i would say our
work like that moment in the middle of
the day where it's just super hot
so we now started to work early
so in the middle of the day you can take
more of a break or siesta
but even this is hard for me personally
i cannot sleep then too warm flies on my
head
so it just makes it
difficult
but i guess it would stop i mean
eventually i guess summer would be over
but also
as the project develop we would create
these places that are a bit more stable
and insulated but at this moment in the
early stages of the project in a hot
summer it's intense
but besides the personal feeling it also
just really affects the landscape this
used to be a green grass field now it's
all brown you see the plants struggling
water flows slowly drying up
which also comes back to us that it's
going to be more risky to be here
because a landscape like this is more
likely to catch fire
but also things like the drinking water
we have it comes from a well so if the
landscape doesn't have enough water it
slowly dries up and we cannot drink or
we cannot live here really
so yeah this might all affect us in the
long term which is also kind of
impressive seeing how much water there
falls here in the winter
and how dry it is now it makes us
realize we really need to become pros in
water management and retaining the water
so it's an interesting long-term
challenge to have
up to the next one
all right challenge number two it's now
actually end of the day i had to take a
pass here camera was overheating i was
overheating but now it's nice and calm
so yeah second challenge is video maker
and this is actually feels like an
ongoing challenge so far in season two
since this year we had felix recording
the first half of the seasons but he
left now now we have two new video
makers just arrived still integrating
but it seems quite a challenge to to
really get this into the project and
making sure it's in our routine because
on the one hand the video makers need to
be there in all these multiple projects
that are going on but also the people
themselves they're going to be filmed
and they need to make sure to think of
filming and
yeah so it's quite hard to really get
this in our daily routine integrated but
kind of essential for the project to
make sure we document everything but
it's quite a big change of doing it
yourself and filming it or
doing things and let other people film
it and make sure it's all coherent so
yeah i think we'll get there but uh
yeah still needs some tweaking to do
challenge number three
um last year we just started on the land
we just put some containers there build
pizza hut
but yeah nothing very official and
legalized this year we're looking more
into that more long-term planning now we
have set up the base camp we also have
more time for this
which means just doing a lot of
paperwork
and it can be quite challenging because
just legalizing this ruin you need to go
to finances to registration office then
to the municipality then a project plan
and just as a funny example as a
reference we bought this land
and we have it on the paperwork we have
a map that says this is your land but we
were here recently and then the
neighbors said hey that small part is my
land we're like oh we have the paper
that it's my land and he says well i
also have a paper that is my land so now
we don't know whose land it is i think
technically it's ours
but also
all the neighbors say it's his land he
had it for generations
so this sort of shows a little bit how
messy it can be here
there also isn't something like a
cadasta or something that registers all
the lands and all the buildings on there
they're slowly setting this up but it's
not really there yet
so we're just getting started in the
rabbit hole of legal work but it's
probably going to be quite an operation
another small challenge is our chairs
keep breaking so we keep repairing them
with little reinforcements because we
don't really have a flat surface so
they're all wiggling around
but that's not the final challenge let
me show you the last challenge maybe
this is more of a personal one
but it feels like the development in
season one went much faster than season
two
also because season one you set up big
things like water electricity roof
internet
and you would assume season two you were
more people so it would automatically
scale up and you can do much more things
but it doesn't feel like that um i think
also because we get involved into much
more long-term processes
things like legalization of uh the
papers which we didn't do at all last
year we just boom we went
um setting up a structure for video
makers to make sure they are integrated
in the project having structures for the
community to make sure everyone is happy
and their sort of systems in place
which all takes quite some time to set
up
and it doesn't
really make sure you can spend all your
time on development we still do believe
it in this for the long term to make
sure we set up structures also that if
someone leaves the community that the
project still continues to go
but at this point it doesn't really pay
off yet but we definitely believe in
that for the long term to make sure we
do it but i guess personally sometimes
it just feels like
it could be faster
but yeah i very much hope for the long
term though
and now finally i'm going to answer some
questions that you guys had
how do you wash clothes at camp
we have a washing machine
and we use natural and biodegradable
soap your project of rebuilding the
ruins seems like a hot topic a lot of
people seem better to knock down the
walls and rebuild them what is your
opinion on this i'm working there
it's uh i must say it's less sketchy
than it looks on youtube
still sketchy
um
i
before i came here i was also saying
that maybe it's better to take down the
walls and stuff
but
from i think from the project camp
perspective in reusing stuff as much as
possible and
being less wasteful
i think
this is
meeting
the goals that we are striving for here
and
i think it's going to be
solid in the end
will the ruin in the forest be renovated
yeah probably all the ruins we would
find around here would be renovated not
sure yet when but
they will
are you planning to have any small
animals such as goat or chicken on the
land
no plans yet but just some flirtations
with the idea of having some chickens
as underground housing an option in
portugal seems like an easy natural way
to beat the heat yes very interested in
exploring this more especially with the
heat going on
but i guess future topic but will be
explored why isn't there more focused on
growing your own food
two reasons one is we actually have a
good local food supplier so there's less
urgency for us to also do it so we
rather focus our energy on something
else
and that it also just really takes time
to do this and there are only so many
things you can do
so for us the beginning is to make sure
we can host more people on the land and
as we can invite more people we can go
more into these kind of topics like
growing your own food
are there any plans replacing the
burning of natural gas a bit similar to
growing your own food makes a lot of
sense a topic we definitely want to
explore but takes time to do as well so
still focusing on first making sure we
can host more people and then dive into
this topic so we can do it properly
because you easily end up having all
these projects not really maintained not
used so we're trying to avoid that to
make sure we can really incorporate it
here for the long term how is the
highway noise this time of the year
still there
morning afternoon and evening
i never heard anything about highways
yeah
you hear it
also now i can hear it
uh
i don't find it much of a problem
i
yeah
i haven't heard anything actually
yeah
is this a highway no there's a plane
it's the hybrid
okay maybe i hear it then
from now on
thank you
will you do fire breaks to try and
protect your land and people i'm not
sure fire breaks would be the best
solution and we're still exploring that
but for sure we're going to incorporate
more strategies to
protect ourselves more from the fire
whether it's getting more water here
planting different kind of trees maybe
fire breaks yeah still to be explored we
actually have a research topic about it
so if you have suggestions make sure to
put them there
have you considered having an array of
small wind turbines
i'm not sure today is a windy day as you
might hear but uh it's not always like
that so we're still measuring the wind
to see if it's viable enough to actually
set up a wind turbine system that it
would generate enough electricity so to
be explored any updates on the waterways
on the land like the creek swamp and a
natural spring
yeah it's quite different actually the
water in this hot summer times and we're
actually now cleaning the waterfall
we're gonna have a video not the next
one but after that probably then it's
ready
which shows very well the changes in the
landscape and the water so i would
highly recommend to have a look at that
but generally yeah much less water
flowing how long do you see project camp
lasting is the lifelong project for any
of the members or it has an expiration
date hmm tricky one for now it's long
life yeah why not
i guess it will be a project that will
take
many years
what's the status of your compost toilet
and update 48 router mansions you can't
pee while you poop have you done
something improvements or adjustment to
the toilet
not really adjustments and i think the
people keep on peeing but no problem so
far sometimes i pee in it
i do pee in there
it's hard to separate you know
how are you thinking about dealing with
the mimosa and ecliptic
it's a good question i guess slowly
slowly like taking down the mimosa
the biggest problem with eucalyptus is
that most of it is not on our land so
actually it's a big question for
ourselves as well are you guys planning
to plant fruit trees as well
yeah we already plant fruit trees
what's the idea behind logging trees on
the map
main reason is for research and the one
hand to understand more what is growing
on the land so we can also plant our
landscape and see this area already had
a lot of native trees so maybe that
would be the potential forest this area
has less potential because it only
mimosas or nothing grows there
and also for archive to really
understand this is what the land looked
like when we came here and what 20 years
later this is what there is now so it's
a good way to just document how it is
currently how do you get sensors further
away from the base to report back do you
use some sort of wi-fi signal booster at
the moment we don't have any sensors
installed uh beyond base camp
so yeah within base camp it's easy
because it's in the wi-fi signal
and not sure yet how we're gonna do this
more on other places on the land but at
the moment we're not really measuring
anything yet because we're also not
really doing anything there
but yeah we for sure need to figure this
out for the future
how do you keep the community happy and
disagreements resolved we'd love to see
if there's anything done to essentially
run a small community from a sociology
perspective
tricky one
well
since i've been here
there were
for as far as i know there were no
arguments
of course there's
probably irritations or stuff i don't
know
but
we have our very special human hour for
this
we try to at least have once a week a
time that we gather all together and
make a bit of a review of the week and
if there is something that is not going
super well that we tried to find
solutions for it
in the past episode you made a contour
map have you already made use of it to
make permaculture design
yeah we're currently actually at the
moment planning more the landscape
we're optimizing the maps adding more of
them or we're actually soon we'll add
them to the research module so if you
want to help out or have suggestions
with them go there aren't you worried
about the microplastic involved with
utilizing products from precious plastic
we've been a bit worried before but we
are not super worried now like we
probably introduced some but nothing
that is not being introduced in another
way
in an environment
which trees are more fire resistant
if you would see the video from last
season there was this guy germano and he
was speaking about the oaks that when it
there is a fire that if you stand under
the oak they just drip some
water
drops and it seems kind of a fire
resistant
will you leave in winter
yeah probably have
to go at some point to work personally
myself
um
and otherwise if we have a house it will
be a bit easier to stay the winter a bit
more comfortable
yeah so probably yes
uh depends on the ruin
do you plan on clearing the mimosa
around to traditional trees
yeah so we try to clear around the
native trees and we
guess that these native trees are gonna
keep the mimosas a bit more away too as
a sustainable way of living avoids the
use of energy and high tech what are
your team thoughts about the high tech
involved in project camp do you have any
wish about low tech solutions to replace
all the non-sustainable staff in the
future
yeah i think in general it's always good
to scale down and get more load tag
because there's massive infrastructure
needed to make super advanced stings so
the more basic you can make your life
the less you need of this however it's
also quite a pop to do that to reduce
these amount of things so i think we
decided to just start where the world is
currently at and slowly remove the
things that we think are not really
necessary and reducing the complexity
but at the moment we really start like
conventional i would say am i allowed to
come and pay you guys a visit in
portugal at the moment we are not really
open for visitors just because it's a
lot already to manage of people coming
and going all the time and so visits and
short visits take a lot of energy and
at the moment we don't have that energy
to give extra so sorry no visits yet
any chances of going there to help or
work as a holiday camp
i would recommend to have a look on the
website you can have a section that says
support and it has a few applications
open where you can sign up to come and
help out whether it's cooking general
help or help with renovation
but the minimum stay is
ideally more than two months
so yeah have a look see if it fits are
any of the large trees solid enough to
build a treehouse
nope not one single dream
not yet not yet
what language do you speak at camp we
try that the common language is english
and when neighbors come by it's
portuguese
right
who's julie
i'm not julie
who's julie it's dutch girl she's a girl
from vanlo netherlands
yeah she's
she's really nice i like her
she's here at the camp too
what are your major favorite things to
do in the camp
i like to
work on the ruin
and play games
actually i like to do everything
it's a bit annoying but i really like
everything i think i didn't do anything
what i don't like yet so maybe
yeah really i don't know
everything about this favorite stuff
maybe it's julie yeah maybe julie maybe
julie
you